from the next entries and beloved
franchises to intriguing reboots and
years in the making dream projects some
truly must-see releases are starting to
fill up the calendar these are just some
of the biggest films arriving in 2021
and beyond it's been more than 20 years
since a new Mortal Kombat film hit the
big screen but one of the most popular
video game franchises of all time is
finally making its way back to theaters
producer James Wan who launched
franchises with saw and the conjuring
has handed the director's chair over to
first-timers Simon McQuoid for this
flick but you can bet his blockbuster
pedigree will be felt throughout the
production process at this point we have
no idea what the plot of the new film
will be the Mortal Kombat video game
franchise has expanded significantly
since Mortal Kombat annihilation at
theaters in 1997 giving the filmmakers
and even bigger mythos to draw from as
they craft their story we also don't
know which fighters will be characters
in the film or which actors will play
them but we can hope to learn more soon
since the film is expected to start
shooting in 2019 the new Mortal Kombat
film is set to hit theaters March 5th
2021 it's been more than 30 years since
he man and the Masters of the Universe
appeared in their own live-action
feature film it's going to take a couple
more years to finally get the characters
back on the big screen but it wasn't for
lack of trying a new live-action film
starring he-man and his pals has been in
the works for more than a decade and at
one point it was even supposed to be
hitting theaters in 2019 I've waited a
long time for this
that didn't happen but now Sony Pictures
has finally announced a March 5th 2021
release date for Masters of the Universe
which will be directed by band of
robbers Adam and Aaron knee no one sent
an AO who rose to fame via Netflix's to
all the boys I've loved before has
signed on to play he-man and while we
have no idea who will play his various
allies and adversaries yet we can expect
old favorites from the animated series
to show up along the way let's just hope
they don't show up like this the
Jurassic Park franchise returned to
blockbuster status in a big way in 2015
with Jurassic world and producer Steven
Spielberg wasn't about to let it stop
there Colin Trevorrow who directed and
co-wrote the first installment always
had the shape of a trilogy in his mind
and that mission continued with Jurassic
world fallen Kingdom in 2018 in keeping
with the established rhythm of one film
every three years the third installment
in the world trilogy is now set to
arrive on June 11th 2021 Trevorrow will
return to the director's chair for the
third installment and will co-write the
film with Pacific Rim uprising
screenwriter Emily Carmichael stars
Chris Pratt and Bryce Dallas Howard are
also expected to return for the film
which will feature dinosaurs roaming
free on the mainland United States
making it a truly Jurassic world beyond
that we don't yet know anything about
the plot John wick chapter 3 Parabellum
is the most successful entry in the
franchise surpassing the entire box
office runs of the two previous
installments early in its theatrical run
the wick film still clearly have a lot
of juice in them audiences are still
coming back for more and Keanu Reeves
seems committed to continuing his reign
of action dominance so it's no surprise
that the third film perfectly sets up of
fourth installment how can you escape
from the light of course you can go to
the dark but then in the dark too it's
also no surprise that it's already been
announced John wick chapter 4 is set to
hit
theatres May 21st 2021 with Reeves back
once again as the titular hit man this
time going to war against people he once
thought he could trust we don't know who
else will be back for the fourth film or
who will write in direct though director
Chad's - he'll ski has already expressed
interest in returning what we do know is
that wick won't get any less dangerous
over the next two years the Batman has
had a long road to the big screen
already and will still be waiting two
more years until it's actually in
theaters at one point the film the first
solo Batman flicks since the Dark Knight
Rises in 2012 was supposed to be
delivered by star director and co-writer
Ben Affleck who'd also signed on to play
the Caped Crusader for Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice but after
Justice League was released in 2017
things began to change first
Affleck seemed to be backing away from
work behind the camera ultimately giving
up the directing role to Matt Reeves
then he seems to be backing away as star
and finally revealed that he was done
playing Batman all together ever since
then Reeves has been working to refocus
the story on a younger version of the
character
now the Batman will reportedly be led by
none other than Robert Pattinson with
Reeves also reportedly eyeing the
penguin and Catwoman as his villains for
the film other than that we still know
very little about where the Batman is
headed but we'll find out more soon the
film is slated to hit theaters June 25th
2021 for a long time the idea that we
would only ever have three Indiana Jones
films seemed both comfortable and
obvious Steven Spielberg George Lucas
and Harrison Ford spent a good chunk of
the 1980s crafting their trilogy and
then it seemed to be put to bed
in 2008 after years of whispers that all
changed with the arrival of the divisive
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull and in an
age when franchises and nostalgia are
often King at the box office it was only
a matter of time before a fifth film
materialized Indiana Jones 5 was at one
point going to arrive in 2019 then that
release date was pushed to 2020 and then
the Walt Disney Company announced that
the film would again be delayed this
time to a
hopefully final release date of July 9th
2021
Harrison Ford will return to reprise the
title role and Steven Spielberg will
once again service director with
Jonathan Kasdan writing the script 25
years after the original film starring
Michael Jordan hit theaters and after
years of rumors about its production we
will finally see a new Space Jam movie
in 2021 the original film was a defining
moment for many kids bringing together
the biggest Looney Tunes stars and the
biggest basketball stars and now LeBron
James is going to do his best to walk in
Jordan's footsteps with a sequel you
know that your friends are cartoon
characters yeah so James confirmed back
in June that he's begun shooting the
film which doesn't yet have an
officially announced plot but will
likely feature plenty of star power in
the form of basketball icons and cameo
appearances Warner Brothers has not
confirmed the film's full cast but NBA
Reporter shams Shannara reported that
the NBA stars recruited for the film
include Anthony Davis Damian Lillard and
klay Thompson meanwhile WNBA stars Diana
Taurasi and Nika Oguma k are also
expected to play key roles Space Jam 2
slams into theaters July 16 2021 for a
period of several months in late July
2018 and early nineteen gems Gunn was
looking for new projects after he was
fired by Marvel Studios cutting him off
from the upcoming guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 those fences have since
been mended and Gunn is back at Marvel
but in the interim he snagged another
comic book project over at Warner
Brothers The Suicide Squad a new take on
the antihero film first introduced by
director David Ayer in 2016 guns
follow-up will focus on a new team
lineup and aim for a different tone than
the original film which means we'll get
a mix of new cast members and returning
stars among those confirmed so far to be
returning are Jai Courtney as boomerang
and Viola Davis as Amanda Waller
well that also seems likely that we'll
see more of Margot Robbie as Harley
Quinn and Joel Kinnaman as Rick
Lag newcomers include idris elba in a
still undisclosed role david dismal
Shahnaz polkadot man and Daniela Meltzer
as ratcatcher also reportedly attached
to the project our guns Guardian spouse
Benicio del Toro will be playing an
undisclosed character and Michael Rooker
will play king shark the Suicide Squad
will hit theaters August 6 2021 nearly
five years to the day after the first
film back in April 2019 a few months
after the release of fantastic beasts
the crimes of Grindelwald we learned
that the third installment in the Harry
Potter prequel series will be arriving
in theaters in the fall of 2021 keeping
up the Thanksgiving adjacent release
schedule already established by the
series the fantastic beast series set
decades before the Potter films and
starring Eddie Redmayne as wizard and
Maja's zoologist Newt Scamander is now
setting up to chronicle the ultimate
Wizarding duel between Albus Dumbledore
and Gellert Grindelwald it was
referenced in the Potter films along
with the true nature of the character of
credence who got some huge news about
his ancestry in the last film the series
is set to last a total of five films
with each one taking place primarily in
a different City
we don't know what City writer JK
Rowling will take her characters to this
time around or what the subtitle of the
film will be but we can expect return
performances from Redmayne Jude Law
Johnny Depp and Ezra Miller along with
the potential for new stars fantastic
these three will hit theaters November
12 2021 nearly a decade ago James
Cameron released avatar a dazzling
sci-fi spectacle that captivated
audiences around the world and
ultimately became the highest grossing
film of all time until Avengers endgame
took the mantle in july 2019 even while
promoting avatar cameron was already
talking about his plans for sequels and
what was at the time of vision for a
trilogy of films set on the planet
Pandora way back then avatar 2 and
avatar 3 were supposed to arrive in 2014
and 2015 but that didn't happen
then three sequels were happening
instead of two with Avatar 2 arriving in
2016 then 2018 then 2020
now with the purchase of Fox by the Walt
Disney Company
the release date has been moved once
again to a hopefully final slot on the
calendar
December 17th 2021 with the following
three sequels arriving in 2023 2025 and
2027 hopefully Camryn and company can
meet the deadlines they need this time
and we'll all go back to pandora back in
2009 just as the Marvel Cinematic
Universe was heating up Robert Downey
jr. launched another franchise with
Sherlock Holmes the film directed by Guy
Ritchie and co-starring Jude Law as home
sidekick dr. Watson grossed more than
half a billion dollars worldwide and
spawned a sequel Sherlock Holmes a Game
of Shadows in 2011 hi you sure you want
to play this game
I'm afraid use after that the Holmes
franchise began to cool down as other
successful versions of the character
carried on their mysteries on television
through Sherlock and Elementary law and
Downey stayed busy with plenty of acting
work and Ricci went on to make King
Arthur legend of the sword and Aladdin
now ten years after a Game of Shadows
Holmes and Watson will ride again
Sherlock Holmes three is set to hit
theaters on December 22nd 2021 a year
later than he original release date of
Christmas Day 2020 Downey and Law are
both set to return as Holmes and Watson
and narcosis Chris Brancato is set to
write the screenplay
though Ricci is rumored to return as
director yet again he has not yet
officially signed on check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]